[Applauso]
a quattro anni
amavo mordere i bicchieri di vetro non
proprio un passatempo leggero ma a me
piaceva quando siamo piccoli facciamo
tutto quello che ci pare
sporchiamo dove vogliamo facciamo i
disegni sul divano nuovo
scriviamo sui muri coi pennarelli
indelebili imbrattiamo tutto con la
pomarola mettendola nel naso nelle
orecchie negli occhi e sugli abiti della
mamma insomma
prendiamo la vita con leggerezza e ci
divertiamo con poco e poi Quando
iniziamo a diventare grandi
Stai attento che fuori c'è freddo Mi
raccomando vai piano
non uscire con il buio quante volte te
l'ho detto E poi dove vai cosa fai
Beh se queste frasi fossero ripetute una
volta ogni tanto ma ci sarebbe nulla di
male parlerebbero di un genitore che si
preoccupa della vita e della sicurezza
del proprio figlio il problema sorge
quando frasi simili ci vengono ripetute
continuamente quasi in maniera ossessiva
per esempio la mia nonna toscanaccia mi
diceva sempre
studia perché sennò i Babbo It's live in
motorino
Meno male ci avevo una fermata di tram
sotto casa
non ti drogare come se tutte le sere
uscissi con il figlio di Pablo Escobar
Stai attento che ti rubano i soldi ci
sono i delinquenti a giro che poi io non
dico io No ma ma che ti hanno rubati i
soldi no perché io ascoltavo sempre i
consigli della nonna
quindi mi chiedo come si fa a crescere
con leggerezza con queste frasi continue
nelle orecchie a lungo me lo sono
chiesto e poi durante un viaggio in
Ruanda ho conosciuto una persona che mi
ha fatto vedere le cose da punti di
vista diversi il popolo dei Ruanda nel
1994 ha subito un genocidio tremendo che
ha segnato la storia di questo paese
lasciando nei segni ben visibili negli
occhi e nelle vite delle persone
l'ultimo giorno in albergo o meglio esco
dall'albergo e vado a cercare dei dei
regali E da questo un quadro
raffigurante un paesaggio africano da
una signora un artigiano di strada oltre
al paesaggio mi colpisce il suo sguardo
di gratitudine il suo sorriso che avevo
già visto in tante altre persone nei
giorni precedenti Torno in albergo
preparo la valigia e mi accorgo che il
quadro Ha le stesse identiche dimensioni
e sicuramente arriverà distrutto Allora
esco dalla dalla stanza per cercare
dello scotch per proteggere gli angoli e
incontro un ragazzo che lavora in
albergo gli chiedo aiuto e lui che fa
torna con 4 fogli di carta
lui non sa cos'è lo scotch perché Ruanda
lo scotch non c'è allora Comunque sia ci
diamo da fare insieme sistemiamo il
quadro all'interno della valigia e
mentre lo osservo dal basso verso l'alto
mi colpisce il suo modo di sorridermi
Allora mi fermo e gli faccio Scusa ma ma
tu
chi sei Il suo nome è Faustina a
vent'anni e quando viene ucciso suo
padre ne aveva solo uno
e me lo racconta con la stessa luce
negli occhi che avevo visto un attimo
prima
gli dico che anche io da piccolo Ho
perso mia madre e forse quella è stata
la prima volta che con naturalezza lo ha
raccontato ad un perfetto estraneo È
straordinario come due persone
sconosciute possano entrare in empatia
così velocemente per un trascorso
similare
Faustino mi stava insegnando qualcosa di
magico
approcciare alla vita con leggerezza e
con il sorriso sempre e comunque
quando me ne Andai ci salutiamo ci
abbracciamo e ci scattammo questa
fotografia
Faustina mi disse diesis best day of my
life Questo è il più bel giorno della
mia vita
[Applauso]
continua a chiedermi come sia possibile
che una persona del genere riesca ad
approcciare la vita in una maniera Così
leggera e mi arriva subito una risposta
tanto semplice quanto potente
e grazie all'impegno
Forse si era impegnato nell'aiutarmi si
era impegnato nel farlo bene
e soprattutto Si stava divertendo con me
Ho capito quindi che per essere leggeri
bisogna impegnarsi anche fisicamente
non prendersi troppo sul serio non
prendersela la prima parola detta male
da un'altra persona non lasciarsi
trasportare dalla negatività essere
leggeri non significa prendere la vita
poco seriamente significa scrollarsi di
dosso la pesantezza significa essere
tolleranti essere generosi
saper ridere
saper perdonare Faustina Segue la sua
volontà decide come muoversi il mondo va
Dunque affrontato un approccio leggero e
distaccato ma mai privo di
concentrazione
perché l'arte della leggerezza si impara
con l'impegno ed è vero è vero leggeri
si nasce ma lo si può anche diventare
a sei anni avevo
due strade davanti a me
lasciarmi trasportare dal dolore della
perdita di mia madre oppure imparare a
familiarizzare con le mie emozioni
grazie a mio padre iniziai a giocare a
calcio iniziare la scuola calcio questo
sport mi ha insegnato tantissimo
il rispetto il gioco di squadra il saper
perdere
sapere che non puoi raggiungere la
vittoria senza impegno e disciplina
la disciplina ci rende le gemme
Lo so lo so la parola disciplina evoca
fatica e non ci viene naturale
collegarla alla leggerezza e invece vi
dico che a me è accaduto Quando giocavo
a calcio
la cosa più importante per me non era la
vittoria
ma uscire dal campo esausto totalmente
qualcuno con la maglia totalmente sudata
consapevole di aver dato il massimo poi
Certamente la vittoria era importante ma
non era ciò che mi rendeva totalmente
sereno Non era quello che mi toglieva il
peso delle prestazioni quando sentivo di
aver dato il massimo per me e per la
squadra
ero soddisfatto mi sentivo leggero
Perché quando si gioca di squadra ci
sono dei ruoli da rispettare e tutti si
devono impegnare affinché il gioco
funzioni e vi posso garantire se
qualcuno non lo fa si vede subito ci
sono però anche delle regole non scritte
il rispetto per l'avversario il rispetto
per il compagno di squadra in difficoltà
il rispetto per l'allenatore
quando un mister parla all'interno dello
spogliatoio tutti stanno in silenzio
E questo vale non solo per gli adulti ma
anche per quelli più piccoli Io alleno
una squadra di calcio i bambini di 11
anni sono stupendi e quando Entriamo in
campo Ci diamo sempre il 5 il segno di
confidenza in segno di amicizia in segno
di accordo e poi ci stringiamo in
cerchio ci facciamo una promessa
divertirci e giocare di squadra
perché nello sport proprio come nella
vita ci sono delle regole da rispettare
e ci viene chiesto di decidere da che
parte vogliamo stare da una parte della
correttezza o della scorrettezza dalla
parte del rispetto o del non rispetto
dalla parte della cura o del
disinteresse con il nostro impegno siamo
un esempio per gli altri e Costruiamo il
nostro equilibrio
A proposito di equilibrio ho visto una
frase su un suo muro di Milano che dice
è sull'orlo del precipizio che
L'equilibrio è Massimo
A 29 anni mi sentivo realizzato avevo
tutto avevo un lavoro vivevo da solo
avevo le mie amicizie tutto girava alla
grande Insomma me la divertico Però mi
sentivo
come su di un orlo di un precipizio
sentivo la necessità di buttarmi
qualcosa di nuovo cercavo un nuovo
equilibrio e allora che ho fatto Ho
preso e mi sono buttato e ho acquistato
un biglietto di sola andata per la città
di New York ora Adesso Pensate un attimo
a New York no pensate al suo caos alla
mancanza di silenzio al traffico ai
clacson alle Sirene assordanti una
giungla e non si ferma mai né di giorno
né di notte che va su e giù rapidamente
Beh sicuramente avete pensato a tutto ma
non di certo all'equilibrio
da vedere ragione perché se vi lasciate
trascinare da lei New York
di trascina dove vuole vi porta su su
fino al cielo fino a prendere le stelle
per un successo per una vittoria Ma
attenzione perché allo stesso momento
quando vuole vi schiaccia
riportandovi più rapidamente per una
delusione
arrivo a New York e cerco lavoro come
barman Perché all'epoca era quello che
sapevo fare meglio
entro in un ristorante segnalato da un
mio amico Ciao sono Mario
Ciao Tu chi sei Sono Giampaolo sono un
barman e cerco lavoro
salta dietro il bancone Fammi vedere
come prepari il cocktail
prepara il mio primo cocktail nella
Grande Mela ero emozionatissimo Mario mi
disse Sei bravo ma già un po' Si vede
che non conosci le regole di New York Si
vede che hai mestiere si vede che metti
molto impegno in quello che fai Ma
ricordati che se vuoi vivere qui
Devi imparare a gestire le tue emozioni
Mario paragonava la vita allo Skyline di
New York ci avete presente che va su e
poi giù va su e poi giù con un'altalena
e mi diceva sempre se puoi stare qui
devi trovare l'equilibrio nel mezzo
quel Giampaolo di 29 anni
ascoltava Mario per trovare il suo nuovo
equilibrio senza lasciarsi trasportare
dalle dagli impulsi dai desideri dagli
istinti dal caos e ritmo di quella città
vedete ciò che ho imparato da Faustina
quello che ho appreso dallo sport
ciò che è una città come New York mi ha
insegnato È il camminare in quella linea
immaginaria che sta tra la leggerezza e
la profondità delle emozioni
tra il talento e l'impegno tra i
grattacieli e la strada
questo
per me è il potere dell'equilibrio
Perché
nella vita di tutti i giorni
non tutti ci chiedono di raccontare
quella storia pesante Quella quella che
ci stringe il cuore che cielo mastica
che non è facile essere nudi essere
autentici essere fragili quella storia
da un viaggio da un libro
da un amico oppure da uno sconosciuto
proprio come è successo a me con faustin
lui era segnato da un destino complicato
Eppure cosa ha fatto ha unito la
leggerezza all'impegno per trovare il
suo equilibrio e alla fine di quest'anno
Forse si laurerà in scienze e tecnologie
nella città di tigani la capitale del
Ruanda
io dal piccolo mordevo i bicchieri di
vetro da grande ho capito che con
leggerezza impegno ed equilibrio si può
mordere la vita
[Applauso]